oh
hello there
it's me
dave your friendly neighborhood youtube
host and according to the red light that
i see
a little up into the right of me i am
live on the youtube
it's true people i have been off the
grid
without news without information without
current events without technology
for 32
days
that is right i got a bonus day there
were 31 days
in august but i got a bonus day because
we started this on a saturday after i
left in a blaze of glory on a friday as
you all may remember let's just recap
some stuff for you
in about ten minutes from now i'm
bringing in adam carolla who is going to
get me caught up on everything i have
literally no idea what's going on in the
world i don't know what's going on on
the covid front i don't know if joe
biden is still president i don't know
anything it was actually quite easy to
stay off the grid this year and i'll
sort of let you know why in a minute and
then just in these first 10 minutes i
want to frame a little bit about how i'm
going to go ahead doing this show and
and doing everything that i do going
forward because i've had a month to
think about it and think about how i
want to continue doing some things
change some things some new thoughts
that i had over the course of the month
etc etc but just to quickly recap
i left in a complete blaze of glory
because you may remember the day before
i left the grid i was banned by twitter
for misinformation about covid because i
said something about how eventually
they're going to want
covet mandates you know vaccine mandates
and that obviously the vaccines aren't
working the way they were promised i was
banned temporarily on twitter for
misinformation but i fought back and i
got a bunch of people to fight back on
my behalf and basically the last thing
that happened to me before i went off
the grid for the next month was that
twitter actually reversed their decision
and sent me an email saying it was an
error so not only did that happen the
day that i left the grid the last day of
july
but i also
released the pre-sale from my new book
don't burn this country it hit number
one on amazon movers and shakers so i
was feeling great i was just like whoa
if you're ever gonna leave like this is
the way to do it beat twitter you know
like have twitter say that you're a liar
and then get them to retract it and then
you know get your book out there and hit
number one on the amazon charts i was
feeling real good okay and then what did
we do well the next day uh david and i
hopped on a plane and we went to the
rain forest in mexico and were there for
two weeks
and all we did was eat fish
a lot of ceviche a lot of fajitas
a significant amount of tequila and rest
on the beach hang out in the rain forest
with the animals uh watch the storms at
night just completely decompress so
before i get to any of the the specifics
on on how i'm going to do the show going
forward and some of the new thoughts i
have i just want to quickly and i did a
little locals live stream earlier for
our members over there i just want to
say to you guys to anyone watching this
right now to anyone that supports me in
any way that clicks these videos you
click like you click share whatever if
i'm if i'm part of your life in any
little way whatever however
insignificant or significant it is uh i
am beyond full of thanks right now like
i really really just had the best month
of my life and i don't know that anyone
on this planet earth had a better month
than i did like we ate right we listened
to great music i exercised every day i
i'm truly right now i'm probably in the
best shape i've been in about 15 years
but i mean that not only physically but
mentally i mean it's spiritually as well
i just feel good i feel ready to fight i
don't know what i've missed i suspect
that when i bring on crowl in a few
minutes he's not going to have the long
list of great things that happened
that's not really the way the news works
anymore like oh yes we did actually stop
critical race theory and oh yes social
justice is done and oh the neo-racism
that they're pushing on everyone and the
destruction of all of our institutions
it's all been reversed everything's okay
like i i know that's not coming right
god only knows what coveted but i don't
even think with covert it's not like
he's going to suddenly say it's wrapped
up and i know a little bit about that
because in the two weeks that i've been
back here in l.a it's like everyone's
masked up again so i can't imagine
anything good is happening on that front
whether that's the reality
of what's going on with kovid or just
the media version of it or whatever
people want to believe or any of that
stuff
but i really just had an absolutely
incredible month and i just genuinely
thank you guys for that and i have to
say that you know when i was away
uh the first two weeks when we were in
mexico you know there were a lot of fans
that were at the uh the resort and
people would come up say hi to me and
everyone was respectful and everyone
knows i'm off the grid so no one you
know
tried to talk politics with me or
anything like that a couple people would
be like come on dave you know you've got
your phone you've got your phone i'd
pull out my pockets i've done this every
year no i got i got nothing with me um
and people were great and people always
say the same thing i said this on the
locals live stream earlier they always
now say the same thing to me which is
dave you keep me sane
and it's like that's a really
interesting thing for people to say to
somebody like if you go up to comedian
oh you're the funniest guy in the world
or you go up to you know uh jordan
peterson and you go you you help me turn
my life around you go up to somebody
that's influenced you in some way an
actor that you love oh i love your
movies but like for people to come up to
you and consistently say you help me
stay sane something to that effect
it's really
i don't even know how to describe what
that's like in a way because in some
ways you've helped me stay sane too
right like when i do this show in some
ways this is a mirror like i put some
stuff back i put some stuff out there
and then it sort of bounces off you guys
and then comes back to me and then and
then i do it again tomorrow and i try to
figure out you know what's the best way
to have people not go crazy i don't want
people to go crazy i just had this great
month
and i that's really what i want to sort
of incorporate in going forward so i
have six quick things that i that i want
to talk about and then i then i promise
we're bringing in corolla it'll get me
caught up on everything but i had six
sort of thoughts
over the last month that i thought were
worth addressing right now before i know
any of the news just things that i've
been thinking about so so first off i
just want to say something on the on the
covid front now again i suspect things
are probably not going great right now
because i'm seeing masks everywhere even
when people are walking dogs again um
but on the covert front in a broad sense
i'm going to go out on a limb right now
and say that no state failed did any
state in the united states fail or did
any country fail that is india still a
country did a little village in chad
somewhere in africa fail because of
kovid has any hospital anywhere failed
now i'm not saying kovid's not real and
all of that stuff but when you step away
from the day-to-day minutia about masks
and mandates and lockdowns and
everything else like were there any
discussions in the last month about
health
i ate really well
in this last month i worked out every
single day for the two weeks that we
were in the rain forest we did the sauna
the steam room and a cold plunge pool
every day for about an hour
i feel like a million bucks right now i
suspect i probably have a little bit of
a better immunity natural immunity in my
system right now as a healthy person
than i did before i went off was there
any discussion on cnn on msnbc any of
these places about just taking care of
yourself and health and natural immunity
and if not why not and how is it that no
hospital like i'm going to just make a
guess here and educate a guest no
hospital in the united states has failed
yet not one
failure like not to say there aren't
stresses but like there's something
about the narrative that just ain't
right i don't know all the answers to
all of that those questions why these
things are but that was one of the
questions i was thinking about directly
related to covid the other thing that i
was thinking a lot about
and i think over the next
however many months and years that i
continue to do this show you guys will
help me figure this out is what do we do
about the liars you know one of the
things that i always talk about on the
show is that we are just in this endless
assault on truth that we just get lied
to
over and over again whether it's that
this election bill is racist or that
brett kavanaugh's a
serial rapist or the litany of things
that they're always you know half the
country is white supremacist whatever it
is it's like we have to figure out what
do we do about the liars and i don't
know that just countering the lies is
enough this is something i talk a lot
about and and the reason i was thinking
about it particularly in in the midst of
this month is although i was not on my
phone doing a lot of things when i was
doing cardio i was sometimes watching
youtube and i usually watch old sports
games but sometimes ads would pop up and
because we're in the midst of this
recall here in california which i think
is going well if i'm not mistaken i have
a little evidence on that um there are
all of these ads on the youtube videos
that are filled with lies about larry
elder that's how i know that the recall
is going well because they're now
attacking larry elder they're all funded
by the way by this guy reed hastings
who's the ceo
of netflix and it's like you just are
willing to lie basically imply that
larry l there is some far-right nut bag
and a white supremacist and everything
else and it was just making me think
well it's not that they just lie to us
about covet and all these things but
they're lying
yes larry elder is a white supremacist
like what are we going to do about the
liars that was something that i thought
a lot about
and that sort of brought me to the third
thing which is that because i talk about
this war on truth a lot what i've
realized is we're really in a digital
war
ver it's basically the digital world
versus the real world and that is sort
of the war that we're facing right now
the way misinformation
can spread digitally and how that now
affects real world things so that you
know you can spread some misinformation
or some whatever you want to call it
about covid next thing you know you're
shutting down real businesses and you're
locking people at home which then forces
them to spend more of their time online
and we have less interactions face to
face and we do everything with masks
like covid and masks really had nothing
to do with my life over the last month i
had a great month i spoke to real people
actually when we were at this resort the
guests did not have to wear masks but
the staff did and i made sure to say to
every single staff member every single
day that if you want to take your mask
down when you're talking to me that
that's just fine with me and they
wouldn't do it right because they don't
they want to keep their job
and there were cameras around one guy
one guy actually did but at the end we
had these two people that were sort of
working with us um
most of the time and i got them to just
quickly do it just to just to smile but
think about that i you know we had two
people that were in effect they were
like our butlers you know so you could
just call them to if you wanted to get
something and it was like i didn't see
these people for two weeks their faces i
got them to smile at the end and that is
leading to i would say a digital
world versus real world war and we're
gonna have to figure that out like the
digital stuff is now leaking into
absolutely everything and then they lock
you down they keep you home they keep
you addicted to these things they can
manipulate the algorithm so they can
make you think all sorts of things and
guess what guys when you when you let it
go for a month it seems pretty clear
which sort of leads me to the next thing
which is also covid related which is
that covid
at this point and again no matter what
i'm about to hear
from adam and whatever has happened this
month and i'm not saying it doesn't
exist and actually i know somebody that
got covered last week and they were sick
for three days and then and then they
were better um
and by the way i was at a family wedding
in jersey a few days ago and it was
great to see actual people and some
people wore masks and some people didn't
i didn't some people did it's okay
everyone made the decisions i don't
think it was going to be a super
spreader event not as far as i know
nobody died but covid is also not just a
virus anymore in the traditional sense
of virus but i would also say it's a
virus in the system
for whenever things get too hot i
thought a lot about this you know for
the last couple years we've been told
that half of us are racists half of us
are white supremacists
all of that nonsense and it started not
to work anymore it was really it was
becoming a meme it was becoming thin it
just wasn't working like you ca it's
just not true and it wasn't working the
way that they that it did work for a
long time like it was we were able to
laugh at it you know the new york times
would call me a white supremacist and
then it was like a joke more than
anything else
but now covet is that new thing that's
in the system where whenever it gets too
hot whatever whatever it is it's like
they could be like all right we got the
delta variant we got the gamma variant
now we got to lock you down again we
gotta shut down your business again so
it's never really going away i mean i
think that's what i've come to now if if
i'm completely off on this i suppose
it's possible maybe i'm completely off
i'm gonna talk to adam in two minutes
and he's gonna tell me kovid is over um
but i i suspect i am not wrong on that
and i think i have uh you know just one
or two more things for you um this is
this is an idea that i thought a lot
about
um before
i went off the grid and it's something
that i've been talking about for about a
year but it really seems now obvious to
me the old world isn't coming back
and i think we really have to accept
that like the old world that world of
say
january 2020 right before kovid
which was pretty good
it ain't coming back like the whole
thing has changed and look how quickly
the entire world change does your life
does the way you
look at the world does it all feel
way different than it did then
do things seem better or worse is your
life better or worse are you personally
better or worse are your relationships
better or worse like all of these things
it's just not coming back and i think
it's important for us to figure out
which pieces we of that old world we
want to take with us to the new world
because the new world's coming whether
we like it or not and i think we really
have to figure that out and that brings
me to the last uh thing that i was
thinking about and then i'll just say
one other thing personally and then
bring on adam which is that i think
probably and i see no way around this at
this point
we kind of are in a cold civil war at
this point ideologically like there are
a set of people that want to burn it
down that have said that they don't want
to negotiate like that this is the way
the world is and america is evil and
western values are evil capitalism all
of these things and then there's these
other people who just want to kind of
live and let live and understand that
the human experience is filled with
inconsistencies and and a constant
battle to better ourselves but that
there's nothing really perfect those
things kind of can't exist together
right like if one set of people is
saying oh you know let's see what we can
do and fix on the margins and expand
freedoms and things are kind of messy
and we can agree to disagree but then
this other sort of cult-like ideology is
like no it's our way or the highway or
our way or we're going to destroy your
cities or our our way or we're going to
take all your stuff it's like that
doesn't really work and you know the
idea that you'd have liberals versus
conservatives people who want to change
things on the margins versus just people
who want things to say the same it's
like all right that can kind of that
tension is good and sometimes it leans
this way and sometimes lean this way
but now we're into something else and
because of because i've come to that
belief i really want to focus on
building things that's what i've done
with locals i want to find more of you
that are building your own businesses
that are building new institutions and i
want to help you however i can and
that's really where a lot of my energy
is so last thing before i bring in
corolla
look i did not have this thing on me
basically for the month i had to take a
couple phone calls and my mom's dog died
charlie little shout out to charlie like
i did hear a couple things related to
that um but you know i was not in the
constant war i was not in this endless
doom scrolling of twitter and what did
these people say and even like i really
didn't think about aoc for a month which
truly is a joy um i didn't think about
any of that stuff i i just enjoyed
myself most days at the end of the day
david and i we got a big green egg we
smoked an incredible amount of briskets
and tri-tips and tomahawks and we ate
great just everything we ate was great
and took care of ourselves and most
nights when my head hit the pillow i
would say to him you know you know i had
a great day today what a great day it
was today and and that is the i believe
that all of us can have that maybe you
can't have it for a month so
consistently and i thank all of you guys
for letting me uh
do this crazy thing that i've now done
for five years
but that's the feeling that i want to go
forward like how do we balance
being engaged people being part of this
new digital world that is here whether
we like it or not
versus what or i should say while at the
same time
being happy
being real people in a real world with
people and and
dealing with that tension
so that being said i'm i'm here i'm open
i'm now gonna hear from adam carolla
who's gonna get me caught up to speed on
the world assuming it still exists and
uh let's see what i missed
i guess i'm a little it's not nervous
i'm but i'm a little trepidatious let's
say corolla
are you there
i am
corolla that was my little dave rubin
oration to begin this thing i'm feeling
pretty good about life you know i make a
good steak normally but i ate well i
listened to music i worked out i'm
feeling good man i i sense you might
wreck the whole thing here
yeah well i'm with you on your
philosophy and i do um
tell people all the time that you just
held your phone up
to show the audience i couldn't hold my
phone up because i don't have my phone
in the studio so
for little tips for for sanity is i
never bring my phone in my studio
because i'm just i i there's nothing i
can do with it while i'm in here it's
just a distraction
and you know the rule is uh i'm in the
studio hours a day and there's never a
phone in here so it's all gonna have to
wait and if you sort of make some of
those rules for yourself it's a better
life
all right
just not having my phone in the morning
you know i try not to bring the phone in
the bedroom even normally when when i'm
not off the grid but just knowing that
i'm waking up i don't know what time it
is and i'm not going to just see what
someone said about me on twitter is the
first thing in the morning and it's not
going to be the thing i end with like
just that alone
is again yeah
to answer your question which is you
know why isn't the media talking about
diet and exercise and
uh you know body mass index and you know
obesity and all these things which is
interesting that you know other than age
the second most important part of not
being killed by covid is obesity
and that they've never they never bring
up age or obesity by the way so
obviously what it is with diet exercise
supplements and the things you've been
speaking about in and therapeutics which
they just poo poo
if they talked about diet and exercise
that would give you control meaning your
control in control over what you put in
your mouth you're controlled over how
long you run on the treadmill if at all
that gives you control they don't want
to give you any control they want all
the control so anything that has to do
with you and your own control being the
captain of your own ship they never talk
about and they don't want to relinquish
a second of it to you so are you saying
i'm right that not one hospital failed
while i was gone and no country failed a
little village somewhere in africa that
maybe doesn't have the protections that
we have here in los angeles none of that
happened i'm right well every time i
turn on cnn they're always talking about
the icu's bursting at the seams but they
never break you know what i mean they
just they're somehow
about to burst but they never burst and
if you talk to dr drew about it when
they give you a lot of those are you
know our hospitals are filled to
capacity
they're always talking about the county
hospitals
there's hundreds of private hospitals
and those aren't filled to capacity so
they leave that part out so essentially
saying you know county usc is filled
but not saint joseph's up the street or
cedars down the street so be careful
when you hear them talk about who's
bursting at the scene all right well i
don't want to lead you so if you don't
want to start with kovid you can tell me
absolutely i think and truly i know
nothing
nothing that has happened well as long
as we're on uh cove well i'll tell you
what we'll circle back to covid we'll
start with the taliban invaded
afghanistan
and biden withdrew the troops
and the airport was uh overrun
and uh there's incredible video and
we'll we'll show it in a in a few
minutes there's incredible video of
folks clinging to the aircraft and
clinging to the landing gear literally
you know last helicopter out of hanoi
it has that it's reminiscent of that so
are people escaping
this is sorry afghani refugees hanging
on to our planes trying to get out of
there because uh the taliban over ran
the so basically
the taliban was in charge of security at
the airport essentially uh the perimeter
the the entire place was overrun by
taliban
and we had
americans trying to get out of there and
you know interpreters and folks that
were friendly to us during the last 20
years
of that skirmish and it was a total
bleep show
and so we actually had to send troops
back
into afghanistan to go to that airport
and try to extract
americans and folks that were considered
friendly to us although we're of course
not successful in getting everyone out
so we so we got some people out and did
you say now we're taking our troops out
like is that is it done i mean if the
idea here so so we're officially leaving
afghanistan is that there were some
rumblings about that sort of at the end
of july i mean i'm you know it's the
longest war in american history i'm
completely fine with ending that war
yeah so what happened was and in terms
of the narrative is i think
most
most all democrats and many republicans
say
let's get out of afghanistan why do we
need to keep this going now if you
listen to guys like ben shapiro
they'll say we had 2500 troops there
and nobody had died in a year and a half
so is that really an endless war
and he makes a good point like we have
troops stationed in you know japan and
germany we we have troops
around the world they're not involved
with an endless war they're just there
you know
and so to kind of paint it
as you know not another american killed
are these sons and daughters are going
over there and never coming back it's
not totally accurate because
in the last you know in the last
uh seven years
they lost you know 10 people
and you know we always have to say it's
all it's always a tragedy anyone lost
you know blah blah blah
understood but
if you have no
fatalities in the last year and a half
is that an endless war right so what's
what's the main media narrative on this
is it that it was somehow a failure of
the biden administration that we lost
this airfield and had to leave and i
mean i got to see the video here
obviously but like
is that what the narrative is or is the
narrative like oh biden is doing what
trump never did or something like that
well the media is has a couple of uh
stratus to it so the first is biden is
pulling everyone out good for him
second one was it turned into such a
cluster f
that even cnn couldn't ignore it you
know what i mean you can't ignore i
should run the video for you
you can't ignore video of people
clinging to the landing gear of a c-130
aircraft yeah wait real quick though
before we throw to the video so that's
interesting though was did they
basically try to ignore it at first the
mainstream media because it was going to
make the administration look bad like
that like it was going around twitter
and the rest of it and then eventually
they just couldn't ignore it anymore
no they didn't do what they normally do
which is
ignore it for as long as they can
because it happened
so quickly and literally overnight and
there was so much dramatic footage
coming from that region
that even cnn couldn't ignore it they
all had to jump into it they then kind
of corrected their
narrative and i'll i'll explain that
momentarily but i think first we should
take a look at the video of the
kabul uh airport and the tarmac and
people trying to flee so we'll we'll
show that
taliban fighters took control of the
capital less than 20 years after u.s
forces overthrew their government
afghanistan's president fled the country
and much of the population is in hiding
afraid of what's next with scenes like
this and unable to get on a flight we
decided to stay
taliban fighters soon declared an end to
the war from the comfort of the
presidential palace just hours after
strolling into kabul just 11 days after
launching an offensive overwhelming u.s
trained afghan forces in cities across
afghanistan
[Music]
there's dramatic footage of people
falling off as it climbs to altitude
obviously to their death so it was so
dramatic that cnn couldn't
ignore it and uh everyone then
agreed that you know this was a total
show
and and that that it was biden's
bop he botched it he bought it and i
understand this correctly so the taliban
is now like basically officially in
charge of afghanistan again yes as if we
just erased 20 years
yes except
for now
taliban is sort of the new government
there we're now dealing with the taliban
as if we're dealing with france and the
leaders of you know macron or something
like that so
and now we hope that isis has reemerged
as well
and so now we're trying to work with the
taliban to keep
isis at bay but there's there's much
more to catch you up on so
okay good start so so uh a country fell
basically and it sounds like another war
is brewing like a pawns on a war with a
new war on the way
it essentially fell overnight so then
biden
you know first he did the damage repair
thing and the generals all got out there
and they said nobody saw this coming
nobody could have anticipated we thought
we had six months to a year we didn't
know we had 48 hours and you know there
were
no there was no way to anticipate this
so says all the generals and all the
experts now my my thing is i like to
play a game called stupid or liar you're
either lying or you're completely
unqualified to do your job
but
then we
then we arranged an airlift to go back
to get
all the folks or as many folks as we
could americans and people with dual
passports and
dual citizenship and
folks that were friendly to us
interpreters things of that nature who
would be killed by the taliban obviously
we arranged an agreement with the
taliban which is let us come back
and biden stupidly said our heart out is
august 31st
[Music]
which was not enough time to get
everyone out right biden brought that up
i don't know why the point is is the
taliban was that just abide in gaffe or
was that just like an actual policy or
was that just one of joe's accidental oh
i shouldn't have said that i'm going to
get in trouble
it's it's unclear why biden gave a hard
out date which is august 31st but he did
and then so that was yeah
i mean is that where we're at right now
yes that's where we're at and almost ins
almost instantly
everyone said we need more time
go back to the taliban and tell them we
need more time than the 31st of august
and the taliban said no deal you said
that's the hard out that's the hard out
so
somehow
we couldn't go back and extend that with
the taliban
but but did we get did we get other
people out in the mean like when did
this all happen was this at the
beginning of the month or has this been
going on just for a couple days or is
this this this has gone on for the last
week and a half essentially maybe two
weeks
so
um
we then
had this giant air lift essentially
where they're we're getting private
airlines involved or you know commercial
airlines involved beyond the military
and
other folks were coming out of the
woodwork trying to help it became just
this huge withdrawal
and
the the conceit was we're going to get
as many people out by the 31st and of
course
gensake and company
in the days leading up to this we're
saying we're going to get all the
americans out but of course everyone
knew that was sort of mathematically
impossible because there was a lot of
people that were stranded outside of the
airport
and they couldn't make their way to the
airport because the taliban had set up
checkpoints everywhere and was in charge
of security now i should
back
i should step back a couple of days uh
with about
five or six days left maybe a week to
withdrawal ever everyone
for the august 31st deadline
there was a suicide bomber
who made his way through the taliban
checkpoint blew himself up somewhere
outside of the airport and killed 13
american servicemen and in women
so that then of course outraged everyone
because those were the people
those 13 had left and then had to be
sent back because it turned into such a
cluster f
and obviously
you could imagine
being the parent of one of those young
marines who came back from afghanistan
and then turned around and went back now
i don't know honestly if it's the same
marine who left turned around and went
back or a new marine but either way
we pulled out of afghanistan and the
next thing you know
your 23 year old son is being deployed
back to afghanistan to clean up the mess
and never comes back
so i mean that's horrible and there's
nothing i can add to that obviously um
but so where do we sort of stand just in
narrative right now is is everyone on
every side saying this is
as as much of a disaster as it sort of
sounds like to me or they try to frame
it as like oh joe's doing the right
thing here because you know we're gonna
leave and it's gonna be messy no matter
what
there's a couple narratives one is is
the white house
shifted to
this is the biggest most successful
airlift in history
so they started focusing on how
successful well
it's essentially
you run your own ship into the rocky
shoals and then you announce this is the
greatest
lifeboat departure ever in a in a in a
in a ship you know and it's sort of like
yeah i i get it we are able to get tens
of thousands of people out in a short
period of time it was a very large and
successful
airlift but obviously
the reason we needed to do the airlift
is because biden botched the withdrawal
the pull out awful lot of people were
rescued after the titanic i think is the
point
that's that's kind of how how they they
couched it now
the uh other narrative
and it's an interesting one
which is uh you've probably felt it it's
an argument that comes from the left all
the time
all the folks on fox news and and many
on cnn and msnbc and mainstream media
were saying
you totally screwed up
this pull-out of afghanistan this is a
this is as big an f up as you've seen on
the world stage in
in many many years
and of course
you'll see this a lot when you argue
with people on the left
they kept saying
we were in afghanistan for 20 years it
was an endless war it was time to stop
the endless war don't you want to stop
the endless war
and
which was not the subject the people are
going yes we want to stop the endless
war you screwed up the stopping of the
endless war you left them and by the way
billions of dollars of equipment so they
have apache helicopters they have
aircraft they have
365 000 machine guns and
you know grenades night vision goggles
like all our high-end military equipment
or much of it was left behind so
basically the taliban has
now we fully arm them too because we
just had to cut and run pretty much in
this successful escape we left behind i
think it was pogrom air
one of their airport the other sort of
the disaster of it is is
and forgive me because i don't know the
names of all the all the airports over
there but we had a big airport that we
abandoned so we completely abandoned the
big airport and we moved into the little
airport and we're trying to conduct all
this from the little airport it's
essentially saying if you live in los
angeles we abandoned lax but we went to
burbank or van nuys and now we're trying
to conduct this out of that and
obviously it's not the same facility and
as we abandoned the airport so did we
with the apache helicopters and
fixed-wing aircraft and machine guns and
all
uh a lot of technology as well
humvees armor cars i mean everything we
just left it so putting aside the people
we left behind and what you're saying is
billions of dollars worth of equipment
that can now be used to do all sorts of
awful things uh the narrative sort of is
that this is kind of good because it had
to come to an end which sort of is like
iraq a couple years ago remember when we
left iraq they had just had democratic
elections things were looking pretty
good then we left and the whole place
fell again so it just sort of sounds
like rinse and repeat is the same thing
yeah and to further that narrative
the biden administration and then all
the talking heads on cnn were like
we had to leave the way we left because
trump cut a bad deal with the taliban
and so we were just honoring the trump
deal so trump basically made this deal
we were honoring it and we had no choice
of course anyone who has a functioning
frontal lobe would say
you
abandon every other trump deal
you know we had deals we had a lot of
stuff going on at the southern border we
had pipelines we had many other deals
that you immediately scrapped the second
you got into office so right since when
can't you scrap a trump deal you know
what's interesting to me is one of the
things i kept thinking about for the
month is that i knew i was going to come
back and you were going to tell me you
know some stuff and it was it's like
it's not exactly the stuff that's
interesting it's more how the media
deals with it that's interesting to me
like it sounds to me that if this exact
same scenario that you're telling me
about right now happened under trump
they would be telling you and it would
be across mainstream media this is the
biggest far foreign policy blunder of
all time and this is an impeachable
offense and this is complete
incompetence and and the whole thing so
that part uh you know i'm not
diminishing the human cost and
everything but just sort of my like
visceral reaction to all of this is is
how does the media spin it is now more
interesting to me in a way than what
actually happened
well what the media does is they
you can't ignore
the calamity part of it you know what i
mean how could you ignore footage of
people clinging to an aircraft you know
so they can't ignore it
so they sort of focus on the human part
of it which is these are refugees these
are interpreters these people have
families they kind of separate it from
biden a little bit and focus not how did
we get to people clinging to aircraft
but who are these people
and then they gave biden a fair bit of
flack because it's it's you know it's
it's unavoidable it's it's like
literally you had to do it so i think
cnn sort of held their nose for three or
four news days and said some disparaging
things about biden and the pull out but
it was always laced with this was
trump's
doing you know this was this was trump's
plan it was not avoidable and then
it then it turned into what a miraculous
achievement
the airlift was
god it's gymnastics it really is and
trump is going to be you know i know
we'll get to the covet stuff but like
it's just the thing in the system
forever when we need the trump card to
be pulled out to blame somebody for
something or say the exact opposite that
we would have said if it was our guy
then you pull out trump when when
something gets too hot you pull out kobe
that that just seems so obvious to me
after stepping away for a little bit
yeah and then as far as you know cnn
goes um
immediately kind of on the heels of this
was a big category whatever hurricane
that blew into new orleans and so they
immediately were able to shift
all of their focus on to you know
flooding and power outages and all so
they they were able to get off the whole
afghanistan story did anderson cooper
get to stand in a foot of water and
pretend that he was drowning did they
get that far yet he's so brazen he did
it in studio this year he actually stood
in a pin of water yeah yeah yeah um
sounds like a freaking disaster okay
it it is uh but again
the biden administration keeps shifting
it back to didn't you want to end this
endless war and people keep saying
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about how we pulled out
wait and just to be clear though so this
august 31st thing that you mentioned
that the taliban saying we're done so
are we officially saying yet we're not
going in anymore and helping anybody or
now or you know i'm sure we're doing
something on the dl but like where is
that at now
um
you know what the
gensake and and others keep saying is is
you know it started off as we're not
going to leave any americans behind then
it went to well there are some americans
left behind
and then there's this weird lessening
things where they go they had dual
citizenship which
is sort of implying yeah well they're
not quite as important as americans you
know because they're sort of dual
and then there's the we don't know how
many are left behind but we think it's
you know about 200 but it's you know
it's not that many so they're kind of
trying to tamp it down a little and then
there's a little bit of
uh blame shame which is you know those
are people who didn't want to you know
we reached out to everyone and told them
we were leaving you know i don't know
why they didn't go to the airport but oh
yeah they couldn't show there were
plenty of those people
yeah
right
obviously you could never run that
gauntlet through the taliban from
wherever you were to to the airport once
you got caught outside of the airport
and then there is the we're going to do
everything we can to get those people
back except for we don't have a presence
there and the taliban is in charge and
then there's a lot of
you know a lot of this what you always
do which is
if the taliban wants to join the rest of
the world on the world stage then they
will you know cooperate with the they
don't want to do that they're the
taliban
right and there's probably
uh you sort of reference this before but
like the translators and all of the
afghanis who've been working with us
there's probably there could be hundreds
of thousands of people that one way or
another the taliban is now going to just
take out and it's like but i get it i
get the inclination of like
it was going to be messy no matter what
you you pick a date to announce you're
leaving and it's going to be messy you
do a slow draw it's going to be messy
and maybe that's why you can't have
20-year wars
well i think the rub is is
the military left before many citizens
did so i think the way
it should have been conducted is remove
all the civilians
and
then remove all the military equipment
and then remove the military troops
and get out you know i i am not uh by
any means an expert on this stuff but
that that makes sense to me and anyone
who's uh over 10 years old right the
people hanging onto planes leave all our
version probably the best one
right so
out of the loop but you know yes so
that's that's where we're at with
afghanistan and and then also there's
this kind of thing where now we're going
to use diplomacy
to pressure the taliban to do the right
thing
which um
historically i don't think we have a
very high batting average with
yeah that doesn't sound like it's gonna
work
all right you want the next story next
story let's go all right so one messy
war situation okay i'm doing okay so far
covet 19 hysteria continues pfizer's
coveted 19 vaccine gets full approval
that's something you probably hadn't
heard of fba grants full approval to uh
pfizer and uh
there's basically
vaccine passports
they're
basically
they're in like so
a couple of things
um
by the way you should know today
this morning
less than an hour before i came here i
got a call from my son who's in the 10th
grade and i had to go pick him up at
school and bring him home because some
classmate
somewhere had covered
and they're sending anyone home that
shared the same class with the kids
never ending man that's what i said
before i bring it on i'm telling you
whatever about you're about to tell me
and the passport thing is a disaster if
that's right or if that's true but like
this thing is never ending they're we're
basically going to split this is what i
really believe at this point i think
there's many reasons for it but on the
coveted front we're going to basically
split into two countries where it's
going to be a certain amount of people
are always going to be masked always
going to be getting booster shots never
going out always going to be locked down
dependent on government and then another
bunch of people are just going to try
their best to live their lives but i see
there's almost no bridging that gap so
wait we we have passports is that
correct now
well new york is requiring you to show
proof of vaccination to
enter bars and restaurants and gyms and
things of that nature that's that's
implemented
it's a lot of some
semantics because you think about it you
know you have biden going there's no not
going to be
vaccine passports you know three months
ago
well
he's not going to implement vaccine
passports but
um
if you go to any
if you go to stanford stanford's not
going to let you in unless you show them
a proof of vaccination if you go to
amherst
uh dr drew's alma mater
you can't come back unless you're
vaccinated they went double masking
indoor and so
i think the game
is the federal government is going we're
not requiring anything no you're not
requiring anything you'll leave that to
stanford and amherst and delta airlines
and every big gym chain and every
federal building or sorry every
governmental building if you're in a
teachers union or truck drivers you'll
just leave that to them so you have de
facto
vaccine passports without the federal
government ever mandating it i mean
that's exactly the same thing one of the
last things that happened before i left
was that story broke about how the
government is flagging posts about
misinformation for facebook so it's not
the government censoring you it's
facebook censoring you and they're a
private company i mean it's it's the
exact same thing well it's it's the
teachers unions that are mandating
protocol to the cdc
you know in in in in a way it's sort of
the opposite it's like that where is
that line between facebook and the
government and where's that line between
teachers unions and the cdc and the
answer is there is no line there's just
an agenda you know actually i did have
to take one phone call about halfway
through august because i was doing an
event in new york city a big tech
debate i was going to debate
you know government involvement in big
tech in november and they told us that
everyone was going to be required to be
vaccinated to be at the event um so my
guys figu you know we had like an
emergency line that they could reach out
to me if something really had to be
dealt with on a timely basis and
basically i said to them i'm not going
to do an event in new york city then
it's not i'm not going to
speak at an event where people are
forced to say whether they're vaccinated
or not if you want to be vaccinated it's
up to you and if you don't want to be
and if you want to wear masks and all
those things but how can i go to a place
where i'm going to speak and demand that
everyone
that is in that audience has to be
vaccinated insane so i think we're
trying to move the venue that was the
last i heard
well also something that's coming uh
recently obviously is
israel is a number of months ahead of us
with the vaccinations so we get good
data
out of israel in israel
just today or yesterday or very recently
mandated a third
vaccine a booster meaning you're not
fully vaccinated until you've had your
third
vaccination your booster so obviously it
went from
vaccinated to
you're not vaccinated unless you have
your booster now according to everything
i've heard and everyone i've spoken to
there is no end to the booster in terms
of the vaccinations there's there is
literally just
getting infected with covid getting
antibodies and hurt immunity but we're
not going to do it with vaccinations and
israel who's amongst the most vaccinated
is being hit very hard right now with
covet
so so adam i don't want to get us booted
from youtube on my day back but is it
fair to say which is exactly what i said
on twitter that got me suspended for
misinformation until they reversed it
the day before i left is it fair to say
that the vaccines are not working as
promised i mean there's video of joe
biden and what that was may or so saying
if you're vaccinated uh you can take off
your mask and you can go live your life
normally so that that was that
misinformation then or
well uh the the mass thing is is a it's
a whole nother kettle of fish we can get
into as well
i would say
the vaccines as promised are not
delivering and and maybe it's an
oversimplification of most americans
with vaccines you know but we sort of
looked at it as
you get your shot you can no longer get
covered
take off your mask go eat at a crowded
indoor restaurant
then it turned into you can get that
that was the promise and that was not
delivered now
who knows what they knew when they knew
it
you know there's certain parts of this
again stupid or liar like i never know
do they not know this or they know it
and they're withholding it
i i assume
that here's essentially how the
government works which i've learned from
being around long enough
you know i used to pass a billboard in
hollywood that said 53 000 americans die
of second-hand smoke every year
i used to talk to dr drew about all the
time
i've never heard of anyone dying of
second-hand smoke have you ever heard of
a celebrity that died you know cary
grant dies at 74 of second hands i've
never i don't know anyone i've never
heard of anyone and dr drew goes oh it
does it's not a thing it's not a thing
and then he pulled an article from jama
once and he said it was an article years
later because he'd heard me complain
about it so much that they they thought
as many as three people died of
second-hand smoke like the year before
so what's what are they doing
well they're lying
but they're lying like a parent lies to
a child you know finish your vegetables
and do your homework or the boogeyman
will get you so that's what they do now
you could say to a parent you're lying
to your child and they're like that's
all right i want them to eat the
vegetables i want to do the homework
that's essentially the relationship
we're now having with fouching the
government and it goes back
it goes back to aids
i i've been around long enough i
remember the whole aids thing it was an
equal opportunity killer a heterosexual
couple or gay couple was all was all the
same everyone needed to wear a condom
everyone it could come out it could get
anyone and it was like that was a lie
yeah
it was a lie they told to try to get
everyone to put a condom on that's what
that there's a rich history of the
government doing this so so wait where
are we with kobe right now is my sense i
just have a gut feeling just from
walking around la for the last two weeks
that people are
sort of more paranoid than usual because
there was that remember that little four
day window we had here in la where it
was like oh people are sort of acting
normal again a woman smiled at me while
walking at the walking the dog i
couldn't believe it like are is it worse
now or better or just no one knows
because it's impossible to believe any
of this nonsense
well there's an uptick because of the
delta variant it's more contagious
uh still doesn't do anything to kids
although they try to weave the kids in
constantly into the mix because that's
the way you scare the moms and then the
moms control everything they're two
years older wearing masks on planes i
mean that was the one that i heard when
i came back from jersey a couple days
ago i had a family wedding came back and
it was if you're over two years old you
have to wear a mask on a plane
yeah we we so there's an uptick there's
an uptick in cases there's an uptick in
deaths the delta seems to be
more
transmissible and the vaccine doesn't
seem to prevent you from getting the
delta variant but it
but it apparently stops the severity of
it
so what they're saying is is everyone
who's hospitalized or most who are
hospitalized are unvaccinated
so
you can get it
you're just not going to be impacted by
it and here's another governmental
lie or stupider liar or whatever
remember about
four or five months ago when they're
really kicking the whole vaccinate you
know really pushing beating the
vaccination drum really hard
a lot of people a lot of voices a lot of
folks that we listened to on our side of
the aisle were saying yeah but if you
had kovid then you're fine you don't
need to get vaccinated and guys like
heads of the cdc and rochelle wallensky
and and fauci and all the experts were
saying no no you still need to be
vaccinated you still need to be
vaccinated and it's like
why do you need to be vaccinated if
you've had it already well now of course
the science has come in and i think
you're 13
times more
suited to not be infected by covet if in
fact you had covid versus the
vaccination so um it was the exact
opposite of what they're saying folks
that we talked to and listened to were
saying why should i get vaccinated if
i've already been infected with covet
and i have natural immunity to it fauci
and rochelle olinsky were going well we
don't know if you have that or not it's
unclear the data's not in we don't know
so you need to be vaccinated a lot of
those people like dr drew
who has a high t cell count or whatever
the biology is of it
was forced to get vaccinated because he
wanted to get on an airplane and go out
of the country
he wanted to go on a cruise he wanted to
go to new york he wanted to do the you
know the event that you spoke of that
you've scrapped and moved so again
it's it's it's it's it is a vaccine
mandate because dr drew as an example
right right got coveted it hit him hard
and he because of his background and his
training and his relationships in that
community have have been have been
tested
constantly to see what his natural
antibodies were and they're off the
charts
but he was forced to get vaccinated
which now they're finding out might be a
little bit dangerous for folks that have
already had it or more so i don't want
to get pulled off youtube but maybe
statistically
there is
some
negative side effects to the vaccine for
a very small percentage of people
but if you have natural immunity
why even chance that small percent
that's basically what we think yeah we
just have a bigger problem here which is
just as you're telling me this and you
know you're on my short list of people
that that i trust to like analyze things
in some roughly decent way it's like
it's just impossible to believe any of
the stuff that gets out there because
even this idea that you just said about
oh well if you're vaccinated then we
know you're getting a sort of less
severe version of covet or something
like that it's like where is there
studies on that like that are real how
would we know if people are getting less
hit less hard physically when they get
covered i also right before i mentioned
this on the show right before i left the
grid
but i have a friend here who's in the
medical field i don't want to say
specifically but someone that i
completely trust and i know this is this
is just personal info but he told me
that he knew nine people this is like
july 29th or 30th knew nine people in la
with covid at that time and they all
were vaccinated and he didn't know
anyone that wasn't vaccinated again i'm
not here to say don't get vaccinated i'm
not here to say don't it's like you do
it whatever you want to do but like it's
just such this thing it's this secondary
virus in the system that seems so
obvious to me the information war around
kovid is is to me at this point more
dangerous than covid
well i think here's the problem with
guys like you and i and then the powers
that be
to circle back
they say
that the people who are hospitalized
are the unvaccinated or the majority of
them are unvaccinated so that's their
data for the severity of it versus
vaccinated versus unvaccinated but to
your point
they keep they basically
are doing what the airline does
when there's a two-hour delay they give
it to you in 20-minute increments right
if there's ever a flight delay they go
it's a 20-minute flight delay and you go
up
i can handle 20 minutes i'll go to
starbucks and then 19 minutes later they
go uh it's gonna be another 20 minutes
and eventually they'll get to three
hours
but they'll they do it incrementally so
what they do is they say
uh the vaccine's gonna we'll be able to
go back to normal when the vaccine comes
then the vaccine comes then they go okay
you can be vaccinated but you still have
to wear your mask then they go uh then
you go but mass aren't effective and
they go doesn't matter wear the mask
anyway get vaccine and then they go you
can get vaccinated but oh yes you can
still get infected with covid with the
vaccination and then they go but if you
get infected with covet it's not going
to be as severe well now we have to wait
for the next piece of information that
that counter that counters what they
just said and the problem is is we're
noticing a pattern it's just the slow
descent to hell that we're all on i was
thinking a lot about that over this
month that it's like every day we just
wake up with some new information or
some conflicting information and we all
just kind of have to play ball with it
because we we don't know what else to do
you know there was that video i'm sure
you saw it right at the end of july that
went viral it's about this two-minute
video of of fouchy flipping on
everything you know one minute he says
masks then he says don't wear masks
because you touch your face more and
they don't really work and then he says
double mask and then he says oh this
type of mask doesn't work and this one
does and it's like we're just average
people trying to live our lives everyone
watching this is just some person that
has to work a job and live with some
people and try to get by that they can't
analyze this nonsense from these i would
say intentionally
conflicting people at this point well
look at the head of the cdc rochelle
walinski she's a piece of work when
she's a piece of work
what did she say that a couple months
back it was like i have to scare you but
i don't want to do it something like
that she said a few things yeah first
off she came out and said
it's safe for kids to go back to school
and then
somebody from the
teachers unions got hold of her and then
she explained that she wasn't speaking
in her official capacity even though she
was standing in front of a cdc step and
repeat and she's the head of the cdc she
was just
she was just drunk at a party and and
babbling i okay so adam just explained
that to me your son in his class or just
any has there been one instance in the
united states in the last year and a
half that we've been playing this game
remember it was two weeks to flatten the
group has there been one instance of a
third grade class where one kid got it
then every single kid got it and all the
kids died is there one instance of that
is there
same thing as the hospitals is there any
instances of any of this stuff
no obviously i'm gonna get shot at the
end of this show i know it i'm on the
list if an 11 year old died a healthy 11
year old died and
let's just i'll i'll put it to you this
way
if there was one
fourth grade class
and two 11 year olds died in that same
class
cnn would be talking about it for the
next 2 000 years yes so that's how you
know this didn't happen
because if it did kids never got sick
and then they get better that's what
happens when you get sick
right so here's the story of covid like
i'm gonna give you
my
thirty thousand foot
view
of covet
forget about science and numbers and
data and biology i'll just give it to
you
um
the whole thing
started
and it killed old people it it coveted
kills old people there was a study out
of stanford today
and the numbers are so astronomical
that it's hard to accurately say but
from 0 to 19
if you get infected with covid you have
a 99.997
chance of survival so that doesn't exist
i've always said if you were making a
movie about a pandemic would this work
nobody just wouldn't people's faces
would be melting in the fifth grade
that's how okay so here's my view of
coven
first things first
um
i'm not a scientist but i am intuitive
and when we
a year and a half ago when we started
hearing about death i kept saying what
about the ages i want ages how come
three more people died in yorba linda
today how old are they how old are they
i kept saying it and people are going oh
it's a hipaa rule or they don't i said
no no
my entire i study patterns in my entire
life i listen to the news and they say a
43 year old mother of three died in a
car accident they don't give her name
but they'll tell you the 43 year old or
a 19 year old pedestrian was crossing
was hit by a truck now all of a sudden
we just have people dying of covet no
ages so i was like what are the ages why
aren't they giving us the ages that's a
very important part of this because
obviously
uh my dad
is 90.
my son is 15. if this kills my dad
there's no reason to panic if it kills
my son there's ample reason to panic
okay there's a big difference you bro
to my birthday party nobody died nobody
died there were some old people there by
the way
here's here's an interesting thought
experiment
if anyone who has a child
if you were leaving
the hospital and before you left the
hospital they said oh you got to spin
the wheel
and you said what is the wheel oh it's
just a two-part wheel
on one side it says
85 and on the other side it says 15.
and you go why do i have to spin the
wheel because that's the age your
infant's going to die
if you spun that wheel that landed on 85
you'd never stop celebrating
you never would stop so that's the
difference between ages if it landed on
15 you would be a heap of tears you'd be
hugging your wife
it would be emotional if it landed on 85
you would literally that everyone in the
hospital would be cheering so that's the
difference so here's the deal it was
killing old people and killing old
people and as a matter of fact some of
the data is
the group
that died in the highest numbers in the
united states was older than the median
age of natural death
so if the natural debt literally that
the highest number i think was like 175
peop americans died or maybe it's 200 by
now but was actually like 82 and the
median death was 80 or whatever so
that's not going to work for cnn that's
not going to work at all how can you
panic all the moms with that kind of
information so what did we do with covet
we left out the ages intentionally of
all the elderly who died and
statistically
are at risk versus the non-statistical
risk of basically anyone under 50 and
what do we do we focused on the kids now
we close the schools well closing the
schools is a metaphor for closing
society schools our society so if you'd
like to close down california
good luck closing down california if the
schools are still open so you close the
schools and then you go well the schools
are closed look we got to shut down
every every restaurant every bar and
every gym because the schools are closed
it was all part of a huge narrative but
it's all the ages and if you want to
know why they're constantly working the
kids by the way another study came out
that said masks essentially are useless
for kids in the classroom
why so much focus on something that
statistically doesn't exist because kids
scare all the moms and the elderly don't
and at what point as someone that just
lived a month of my life having nothing
to do with kovid as i said i was at a
resort for two weeks where we didn't the
guests didn't have to wear masks the
staff did i didn't want my guys to wear
masks and i told everyone that they
didn't have to and i was sorry that they
did but that made me think well we're
going to end up in a class war over this
thing too because the service class and
the blue collar workers and your
construction workers and your servers
and waiters and waitresses are all going
to be wearing masks while the people
that can afford to not do those things
so now we're going to have a class war
that's why
yeah you missed a good visual which was
nancy pelosi had a big
fundraising
outdoor dinner with all the gentry there
no one was mass but all the poor
hispanics that were bringing them the
ceviche were massed up and that that
will battle and cap that encapsulates
the entire moment we're talking about
just but that's what they like that's
what they like actually because they're
the elites while they pretend that
they're fighting for the average person
so we're gonna have this weird class war
that's gonna kick in because of this
thing
the kid part is just evil i mean i was
just when i went to this family wedding
i got to see some of my nieces and
nephews who i haven't seen much of in
the last two years and i'm talking to my
my nephew my 11 year old nephew about
masks and it's like he doesn't get to
see his friends as much anymore and
they're doing everything online so even
when they're playing playstation instead
of back in my day when i would sit in
the same room and play you know nba 95
with my buddy they're doing everything
online now and they're just gonna break
kids ability to be social i mean it's
all it's all here at this point do you
think i'm crazy when i say this because
i thought about this a lot for the month
at this point and again i don't have
every data point i know you're giving me
whatever you can here to me you open up
absolutely everything no restrictions
any and then everyone makes whatever
decision they want to make for
themselves i went to the mall yesterday
i got a nice new jacket and everyone's
walking around the mall is basically
empty because people are afraid of
humans but no one there's no evidence
that anyone in that mall is sick or that
if you were you could you probably
didn't go to the mall but if you want to
go and you're afraid you wear a mask but
i at this point
covey just wouldn't exist in a certain
respect if i was running the world
because people there's risk in life
that's it that that's just it
and you make some decisions for yourself
i know i know i'm a radical freedom
expert i know i know well no no you're
not you're a covet denier
that's this that's that's the new world
order if you say the insurrection was a
riot then you're saying then you're
denier and it's like no just just
accurate in my terminology but
so here's the here's the long and the
short of it as i can tell um california
especially where we live is not in the
business of letting you make your own
decisions and they've not been in that
business for a long time people think
this is new it is not new i'm a builder
i formerly was a builder and i continue
to build have fun building something in
california
have fun
have because they will give you
permission and they will dictate every
aspect of that build so this notion of
all of a sudden this thing has reared
its ugly head no anyone who's had to do
business in california and especially
had to build something in california
knows this has been around for a long
time it's been
hit with creatine it's been supersized
now because of this but
this is the this is the state we live in
and have lived in for a long time also
can we shift for a second to maybe some
good news since you're mentioning
california please god if i ask the good
lord for one thing on this day that i
come back to the grid please tell me
that the recall situation is going well
i have a sense
that it might be because i did do one
thing over this course of the month
related to all this i did have one
dinner for larry elder because there was
a fundraising thing that i felt it was
important that i was at to help help him
make some connections
um and everyone knew i was off the grid
so i didn't hear anything but i i got a
sense this was about halfway through the
month that there was some momentum there
please god adam even if you want to lie
to me a little bit give me some hope
here we got 14 days like please a little
momentum come on
well
i think larry does have some momentum
because
the la times is launching attack pieces
against him and so is
cnn on this that's as good as it gets
that all you need is the attack pieces
that means it's going well perfect right
uh uh a headline out of the la times
that you'll particularly enjoy was that
larry elder
is the new face of white supremacy
and i i oftentimes think of you
and i cite you a lot because your story
of going from the left to the right yeah
and saying
it seems impossible that everyone who
disagrees with us is racist
it's it's it seems improbable
statistically
because they're we're talking about
economic policy
except for everyone i'm arguing with is
racist if i'm on on the left and so
here's the thing um
they are so
out of
ideas on the left and can do nothing to
larry elder's policies they can't attack
his policies
they literally just have sexism and
racism those are the two things so
they're focusing
um cnn with jim acosta ran a piece
that was so laughable it was insane they
pulled a clip of larry elder's radio
show from four years ago where he made
an innocuous joke about uh women
marching in the in the million woman
march and the gist of the joke was
trump has motivated more fat women to
get off the sofa
in march than michelle obama did with
her health initiative it's a good joke
and it's a tr it's true
and then jim acosta called it disgusting
which by the way makes him makes him
he's such a clown he's such a but
okay i and by the way he's a liar he
doesn't think that's disgusting but the
point is cnn has entered the fray
that is great so it's getting so it's
finally getting national attention
that's that's what i was saying right
before i went off the grid that one of
the types of fake news is that the media
just ignores things it's not just they
lie about everything it's that they
ignore certain things so if cnn's
hitting this right now
that is spectacular
yes they are now
one has to say which i always find it's
something i i talk to drive dr drew
about privately all the time which is
i do not get the los angeles times
here's an interesting statistic
um because i went looked it up
california always looks at itself as
sort of the vanguard for all progressive
movements like as california goes so
follows the nation and the world you
know we set
we're the leader in gay marriage and
we're the leader of social justice like
we're the leader
um
we've had governors for over 150 years
we've never had a black governor
never so california
has never had a black governor we've had
governors since 18 since 1849.
we've never had a black governor
and the l.a times who's on the vanguard
of diversity
is going to attack the first potential
black governor of california so what are
the rules
friends on the left are the rules we
want black people in positions of power
because i don't think that's the rule
just be clear we want black people who
agree with us in power and if not you're
candace owens or larry elder you're not
even black we like which is minorities
who bow forever that's what it is we
don't like gays we like gays who bow
forever we like black people who bow
forever we like women who bow forever
look it sounds to me i know i've been
out of it for a little while sounds to
me like the l.a times has gone full
white supremacist
i don't but my whole point is how do you
do this with a straight face
that's my whole point and
all you have
is
anyone who wants to run and and all
larry elder talks about is school choice
and regulation and border security and
all that kind of stuff and all they talk
about is
racism
and by the way if you want to know how
brazen they are
they're doing with a black male i mean i
know you know that but i mean it's like
they're so committed to their calls of
racism for anyone who opposes them that
they will do it for a guy who was born
in south central and attended crenshaw
high
that's how committed they are to to
calling everyone a racist and by the way
on september 14th the key thing is you
just have to vote yes or no on the
recall that's the beautiful thing so who
in their right mind is going to vote
that day and be like yes everything's
great even if you're a complete
progressive nut bag who in their right
mind would go to the polling place that
day and be like yes we want more of
gavin newsom we want more homelessness
we want more drugs on the street we want
less policing all of those things like
that's why i think there's some hope
here because what was it something like
1.7 million people hand signed the
recall because you had to do it hand
signed right you couldn't do it online
so those people are going to be
incentivized those people are going to
be excited to get out there on the 14th
how many of new sims people are going to
be really excited unless you can trick
them into thinking that the black man is
a white supremacist
wait so are there any numbers are there
any numbers like polling numbers or
anything or you just the sense is that
we're in good shape here i i saw a graph
that uh your people provided me and i
have to i have to access that
because i have a large stack of papers
to get into with you but
it was i think it's sort of within the
margins of error i think uh you know
later it's amazing that's amazing
larry
we're throwing it up right now that
that's awesome
yeah 46.3 versus 50.6
i don't
i don't know how how old this uh survey
is i'm guessing it's fairly current if
your people
dug it up but it's it's it's there we're
within a few ticks and um who the heck
knows so um so that's good news i'm
telling you man i'm going to devote the
next two weeks of my life to making this
thing happen maybe i'm crazy but you and
i stayed you know knowles shapiro the
rest of those guys they fled but what if
corolla and reuben lead the tr and dr
drew you know lead the charge to save
this freaking thing and then instead of
oh the country goes as california goes
it's the country gets saved because we
save california i'm not kidding i'm
devoting the next two weeks of my life
to this no matter i will do i just i
actually just texted i did pick up my
phone this morning to text and i texted
larry i said anything you need anything
i'm there so let's see yeah well
look um
again
you cannot do worse than gavin newsom so
this is different than gavin newsom and
uh i said to somebody once who said uh
this is months ago before larry got into
the fray
i said uh who would you like over gavin
newsom and i said one of those plastic
owls that people put up on their sign at
the restaurant at the beach so the
seagulls don't crap on it
yeah that would be fine
the owl wouldn't be destructive
you'd just just be just be there by the
way all right wait one quick thing on
this which is um you know i've seen
these ads on youtube as i was watching
just old basketball games where this guy
do you know who this guy is this reed
hastings guy he's the ceo of netflix and
he's been basically gavin newsom's uh
piggy bank for this thing so he runs
these crazy anti-larry elder ads and
it's yeah implying he's a white
supremacist and he's an anti-vaxxer and
in one of the ads they basically are
like voting for gavin newsom is a life
or death decision i'm slightly
paralyzing but that's basically what it
says the implication that larry is going
to kill your children and gavin newsom
who you're telling me kovit's not going
so well he's been in charge this whole
time he's obviously going to save your
children these people the lies man i i
these are not good people
well i'll circle back
just to put a button on covid all right
we got some good news today all right
just so people know and and it's it's
anecdotal of course but
here's personally my own experience with
covet
um
i i know a few people there's a bean
baxter dean baxter from kevin and bean k
rock started many years ago with them
uh
bean
got covered got hit pretty hard
recovered fine
he did everything right according to him
masking and washing hands and spraying
everything down with lysol and not
leaving the house except for for you
know to go to the essentials and he did
everything he's a very festivious guy
and he did everything very well he got
it uh mike august who you know books all
my live shows and does all this stuff i
travel the country with him we play
clubs we sit on airplanes next to each
other we stay in hotels we share ubers
whatever
um
he
doesn't get it then gets vaccinated then
does get it
i mean that's what i referenced before i
uh don't do anything right i never wear
a mask i never wash my hands i've never
washed my hands since before this i
don't believe in it by the way i believe
it does more harm than good separate
subject
i do not sterilize anything i stay
every club date i play i stay and shake
the hand of 200 people and take a
picture of my arm around 200 guys all
massless all indoors and then when i'm
done shaking everyone's hand i go back
to the green room and i grab a handful
of cashews before i wash my hands and i
eat the cashews i have never gotten it
so you tell me
what doing everything right versus not
doing anything versus doing some of the
things this is the whole gypsy
lady
aspect to this you should be studied
like a mutant you know what i mean maybe
that's your superpower you're eating the
cashews and you haven't croaked
how many how many people do you have to
hear go i did everything right and then
i killed it before you realize well what
is right
then how does this work and the answer
is we don't know wait can i just ask you
one other thing that's co it's covid and
california so are we in any sort of
lockdown right now do you are you am i
like i'm with you i don't wear it if i
get asked when i go in then i'm not
there to fight with the sales associate
at bloomingdale's and i'm trying to be
nice to people and all of that stuff but
like what is the actual policy right
like are there some states that are i
assume no one's locked down anymore but
are there some states that are
doing more math stuff and some kind of
letting people live is florida still the
only free state we got left
yeah
they're they're doing what they've
always done texas is doing that as well
alaska as alaska i was there they don't
care
um i suspect california would like to
impose more draconian rules but we're
right in the middle of a recall yeah and
i don't know what gavin newsom's
relationship with covid is i i think
gavin newsom's relationship two weeks
out from the recall vote is
i will keep beating the drum of how
dangerous it is and how you need me to
save you from covid but if i shut down
restaurants
it's going to be a shitstorm and i don't
want to do that 10 days before
the the
recall vote on top of the fact there's
no evidence that locking anyone down did
anything but we've got to stop that
black white supremacy so i get it again
that's right i'm very excited about this
elder thing man that's the best thing
you could have told me well maybe more
good news with governor cuomo
resigning
i know you probably heard some rumblings
of that
no rumbling sign no
yeah wait he's not the governor anymore
he's not the governor
he is resigned
no
well because of the
the sexual stuff or the the murder stuff
right it's not it's not the 10 000
people he said to the death with the
nursing home it's the slapping chicks on
the ass
aspect of uh his government governing
that uh got him out
and gun i'm shocked i'm actually i'm
completely shocked
i'm i'm sorry and that i forgot you
didn't know because this whole thing
he resigned and he gave himself two
weeks to resign and that was about a
week or ten days ago so as i sort of
back date this whole thing this must
have been going down while you were
ubering to the airport to leave town
like you just missed this one wow so he
is so okay so he so technically he's
still in that window or no he's gone no
no yes he's gone so he was gone a week
or ten days ago
and and there was you have to add two
more weeks on to that so you just missed
it in other words is what i'm saying and
and one final moment was there a video
was because i really thought he was
gonna get by it seemed like the ship had
sailed and it was like yeah you killed
all those people you smacked a couple
girls on the ass but
we're moving on
i'm shocked yeah i'm completely shocked
they uh they they took his emmy back by
the way
does he have to give the 5 million on
the book advance back too
that uh that he pocketed i don't think
they're going for that but they got the
emmy recall
um he
know that the thing that's interesting
about
this and the me too movement and i've
talked to mark gargos about this many
times it's sort of like
the me too movement works this way
if
it was still if it was the law
you'd say well you can have one
murder conviction
or you can have 11 jaywalking
convictions and it would be the same you
know what i mean so it's an interesting
thing which is another woman has come
out against cuomo and i'm not here to
defend cuomo but another woman has come
out against cuomo what happened well he
put both his hands on my cheeks and he
kissed me on the forehead at a wedding
and it's like
okay and then at a certain point the
news goes now there's 11 women isn't
that enough for him to resign it's like
well not 11 jaywalking tickets that's
not enough to give a guy a murder wrap
right so wait is that really what
happened that there was just one more
and finally the dam broke because nobody
cared it was just like ah and by the way
i'm not you know you know my feelings on
this which are the same as yours about
evidence and you know accusations are
just accusations and a lot of the stuff
about you know tapping someone on the
butt or kissing someone on the head like
it's life like you know but i'm not even
making a judgment call on that but
you're telling me it was just another
one and then it just the scale tipped it
it was essentially there seemed to be
one credible one where he put his
allegedly put his hand up a blouse or
something the rest was a lot of paths on
the bellies and
finger dragging down the spine saying
hey you you know just kind of weird
semi-creepy stuff ultimately didn't he
ask someone to touch his cannoli or
something wasn't there there was
something cannoli related i think i it
became this sort of
saturation level like people got to a
saturation level with it but essentially
it wasn't sexual abuse it was abuse of
power and if you all know
the one thing the left has to really
come out against is you know a white
male heterosexual male in a position of
power
that is being inappropriate with women
who are well beneath him
in the socioeconomic pecking order so
they couldn't ignore the abuse of power
and it really wasn't i mean again
this is my opinion it was less
sexual abuse because there wasn't any
real defining
right he ripped my blouse off and he
raped me repeatedly it was all an abuse
of authority right it's not like it's
not like he took a cigar and say he
sodomized an intern while on the phone
with trent lott in the white house like
it wouldn't be that right yeah not not
like that whole jimmy carter incident
you're speaking of yes not that jimmy
wait so dare i ask i don't even know who
the attorney general or sorry the uh
with lieutenant governor uh
but i'm gonna guess it's probably
somebody worse so you have to be careful
what you ask for well
i don't want to pop your balloon after
we're sailing so high but uh little
known fact it is now the governor what
no it's gavin newsom he has dual coastal
citizenship and he's now running both
coasts so sorry dave oh terrible
terrible no but i assume is it someone
just like further left yeah it's a it's
a female lieutenant governor who's uh
stepped in to fill the void so he's out
and again this is the problem the left
never stops talking about every woman
needs to be believed and you know after
they do their hit piece on kavanaugh and
all that kind of stuff and then when it
happens to one of their own there would
be insane hypocrites to say well you
know kavanaugh's a rapist but cuomo is
just fine
and they pin themselves into a corner
essentially because they never stop
bloviating about every you know every
woman needs to be heard and every woman
needs to be believed and now what are
they going to say there's 11 women don't
listen to them it's exactly what i
always say about you call everybody a
nazi it's not what you're doing to all
of them it's what you're doing to
yourself because you can't suddenly be
like ah that one i call the nazi that's
not the nazi well it's it's vaccine
mandates and sorry vaccine passports and
ids i mean this is a recent story that
you may have missed but you probably did
the math
uh you have all these governors of all
these blue states explaining that
showing an id to vote is jim crow 2.0
and all these same governors have now
legislated that you need to show an id
and a and a vaccine card to enter a bar
a gym a restaurant a federal building a
public building a public space and
obviously
in new york city it's pretty
astronomical in terms of the groups that
have not been vaccinated cnn would tell
you it's a bunch of guys driving ram
pickup trucks with american flag
but statistically it's the
african-american community so
basically two-thirds to three-quarters
of black new yorkers are not vaccinated
and you've now told all those people
they can't enter a bar or restaurant
without providing an id but that it
would be jim crow if they had to provide
an id to vote so you've crapped all over
your own point well that's why the lying
about the voter id laws was so dangerous
it was such a dangerous game that they
were playing in georgia and texas and
some of those other states to keep
saying it's racist to show an id because
congratulations here we are now you want
us to all walk around with your your
little vaccine mandate okay your little
card well i'm not showing my id for it
god it's evil that's what i'm talking
about when i talk about just like evil
just spreading throughout the system
these liars they and that's why they
always go crazy right if you're just
lying about everything all the time then
you always have to ratchet up the crazy
i'm shocked about this cuomo thing all
right so that's good that's good
yeah well on the same
you know we're now
cnn's all over the texas abortion bill
and all that kind of stuff and now it's
sort of again when you're talking about
sort of crapping on your own points you
know nobody should ever have to tell a
woman what she can do with her own
health or her doctor you know it's
between her and her doctor you must get
vaccinated that's mandated by the state
well don't you feel like those two ideas
kind of are at loggerheads like
you can you're an autonomous zone you
can do whatever you want with your own
body if that means an abortion in the
third trimester that is your business
it's nobody's business but you and your
doctor but of course if you and your
doctor decide you don't need a
vaccination you'll you shall be run out
of town wait so what this is the problem
what's going on with this abortion bill
i'm going to guess they're trying some
probably moderately decent restriction
on abortion that most people would agree
with and as you know i'm begrudgingly
pro-choice so i might even agree with it
but now you're the left's going to show
me how bananas they are is that where
we're at i don't know all the nuts and
the bolts of it i think part of the
reason the left is going bananas on it
is because it's six weeks versus 13
weeks or some version of that it's a
it's a shorter period of
window where you can get an abortion i
do have this bigger philosophical
question
for you
which i never really thought about
because i grew up in california i grew
up in los angeles i worked in hollywood
every one of my families you know
liberal and progressive and i just sort
of stood in it my whole life i never
really thought about it abortion doctors
if i remember correctly right
yeah well
um
i i wish someone was that professional
in my family but
here's an interesting just sort of
thought experiment i don't know if it's
ever this thought has ever entered your
mind but it just entered mine this
morning when i was watching cnn trying
to figure out so everyone is outraged
over
the governor of texas essentially going
after abortion okay
we live in california
we have a progressive governor
progressive mayor progressive
legislators
we live in a very blue
state and it's a supermajority of
democrats
they
all day every day push their agenda
they want they want their they want
schools to be closed down because of
covet it gets closed down they they want
uh 1619 curriculum taught at school
they want to transgender this like
they want uh the minimum wage should be
15 bucks you name me the subject that's
their progressive agenda and they go for
it all day every day and it's by the way
why california is a box now because
they've been doing what they've been
doing for too long we could tolerate it
for a while we're at a saturation point
but fine i think i can slightly prompt
you they're good guys adam that's the
answer right there we live in a
progressive state and they have a
progressive agenda and that's what
they're doing yeah
why is it
when there is a red state and a
conservative governor well that's his
agenda
i mean cnn should understand it doesn't
just work one way it's not blue state
blue agenda
red state no agenda
no a red state is a red state and it has
it has a conservative governor and a
conservative is against abortion so
that's what he's doing right but it's a
great point and again it gets to why i'm
always so interested in the media
narrative more than the specifics
because of course you you vote in people
to do certain things but the media is in
on it with the lefties and the democrats
so they like their policies so their
policies will always be good and the
republican policies will always be bad
you know real quick on the abortion
thing you know in my book i talk about a
12-week cut-off with very limited
exceptions to that you know real
health-related things either for the
mother or for the child but i can tell
you this adam and i think you know a
little bit um on the personal side on
this you know david and i have been
trying to have kids for a while we've
had
two miscarriages with our surrogate and
we've had a further complication with a
new surrogate
but this idea that this isn't a living
being
somehow six weeks or 13 weeks or 20
weeks in or certainly eight months in is
crazy i mean i know when they've taken
my sperm and the egg and put it together
and they now show me how many embryos we
have we're allowed to say do you want to
implant or a male or a female after like
three days basically they do genetic
testing it goes from a blastocyst to a
full embryo all of these things so the
idea that even though i take this
position which i know is a lot of
conservatives are not happy with me
about although some will admit privately
they're somewhere there too
because they want to take a more
libertarian approach and understand that
life is kind of messy on the margins and
all that it's like these people that
will tell you gender doesn't exist it's
like then what is my fertility doctor
telling me my fertility doctor's saying
do you want to choose the male embryo or
the female embryo is he a liar or a nut
bag
and is that a life well i'm pretty sure
if you can tell if it's a sex then it's
a life so it's like this is where again
if you just lie about everything which
is what they do
then you you end up lying about so much
more that it's not a life and sex
doesn't matter in any of those things so
i for me six weeks is pushing it um i
think 12 weeks is fair but that's where
a healthy society could have an honest
debate but obviously that's not the
society we live in
yeah i agree with you i'm pretty
moderate on the subject this sort of
notion you know there's a couple of
things which is you know it's my body i
can do what i want with my body well
it's not your body it's somebody else's
body that's living in your body so let's
let's sort of be clear about it also
obviously
if
somebody gave birth and then drowned the
kid they're up for murder so
it's not exactly yeah you know
neither here nor there in terms of
whether it's a human or not i'm with you
i don't really have a dog in the fight i
feel like i understand both arguments
there's a lot of hyperbole on both sides
the left is sort of going nuts at this
point because they're celebrating
abortion and talking about is you know
women don't have access to health care
and stuff like that they go nuts and go
hyperbolic on everything all the time i
get it i'm with you
pick what we sort of agree on as a
sensible hard out for the abortion and
that shall be the law of the land that's
the way i've always approached it myself
yeah i i and by the way the funny thing
is that you and i can both take that
position which i know that more and more
of let's say our right leaning or
conservative audience will not like but
no one's going to send us a death threat
over this no one's going to try to
cancel us over this when people read my
book and i took that position i met
literally or got emails from hundreds or
thousands of people that said dave i
love the book i disagree with you on
abortion but that's okay and it's like
that is the fundamental difference
between broadly what happens on the
right these days and what happens on the
left but everyone knows about that what
else did i miss what else did i miss
all right well i have to go pee so i'm
gonna do one more okay
the uh something that i
i drilled down on
on my podcast which i thought was
interesting that happened
joe biden's still president that thing
didn't fall apart
uh no he has uh well in or he's still in
the name i don't know if his spirit is
there but but he is
technically still president university
of wisconsin moves 70-ton rock off of
campus to fight racism
so i'm pretty well versed in this story
because
i took notice of it i kind of drilled
down on it on my show
there's a rock a boulder a 70-ton
boulder that's billions of years old
because it was pushed there by a glacier
a billion years ago was uh on the campus
of university of wisconsin was named
after the first chancellor dean or
president or one of the presidents of
the university of wisconsin who was like
a botanist so he was you know
he was a tree hugger
and uh he was that was 150 years ago and
they named this boulder after him
uh you're probably thinking right now
why did they have to move a racist
boulder
you know i don't ask these questions
anymore actually it's like right yeah
this is what they do this is what they
do um
in a article in a newspaper from
1925 they use a racially disparaging
term for the boulder for some reason
it's unclear why but in one article from
they called it something horrible and
for that reason
uh 73 years later or 72 years later
whatever it is oh i'm sorry
90 90 yeah i was 90.
97 90 98 years later whatever it is
they must they've been asked to remove
the boulder and they have removed the
boulder because it was offensive
to uh people who were in the uh in the
community out of the black student union
or something but here's my and they
pulled the plaque off it which had the
name of the president who was the
botanist guy like he wasn't
he wasn't
where where where do they put the racist
boulder where is the boulder now it's
still
it's still on the grounds of the
university of wisconsin they just moved
it
because we all know that's going to help
the kids in the inner city of chicago
right problem's over but here's what i
said to everyone and
i'd like your take on this
you know when i objected to them pulling
down statues
i i always when you're dealing with the
progressive left it's called a
progressive movement it's got the word
progress and movement in it it's there's
no signs of it's stopping or slowing
down so first they're going after civil
war generals who are on the wrong side
of history and they go what's wrong with
that well what's wrong with that it's
the next ones they go after is lewis and
clark
and now they're at a boulder
that's what's wrong with it it never
stops you can't progress you can't
progress for the sake of progress you
have to sit progress for the sake of
equality basically but yeah they just go
and go and go so congratulations we're
not just removing rocks we're just
moving them that's actually moving them
that's like the more interesting part of
this story is that it didn't they didn't
blow it into smithereens they didn't
hide it underground they just moved it
again
we must be out of problems that's that's
the one hopeful sign of this whole thing
corolla i am uh
i'm shocked here covid all right that
stuff it is what it is we got some hope
out of california cuomo's gone
the afghanistan thing sounds kind of
messy so i'll obviously have to do a
little homework on that for the rest of
the day uh and then and the rock that's
it
that's right nothing else nothing else
oh how are you doing oh speaking of the
rock there is a cop who looks exactly
like the rock that story happened like
10 minutes ago but uh
i'm doing well i'm sitting here in my
studio in uh california and uh i'm uh
you know i'm keeping it keeping it
together busy traveling doing shows all
around the country writing my sixth book
and working on documentaries
i can't complain you can help me with
this elder thing for the next two weeks
i will send me send me a text because i
i've been i've been uh wanting to reach
out to larry myself yeah we'll do all
right listen i'm going to let you pee
i'll i'll finish up solo for a couple of
minutes here but i really i thank you
man for doing this i i know this was a
heavy lift in between shows for you and
a long schedule and everything so it's
good to see you and uh i told the i told
everybody when i got back i really
perfected the smoked brisket this month
so
yeah yeah we'll do it all right i'll see
you at the grill thanks buddy all right
be good adam
wow i don't even know what to say right
now the cuomo thing is just an absolute
shock like i really thought that the
ship had sailed on that one um you know
and i don't like the idea of people
being destroyed for things that maybe
they shouldn't be destroyed for and just
the general destructive force of
cancel culture and everything else but
you know you you guys play by these
rules and occasionally these rules are
going to get you so that's interesting
the afghanistan thing i need to know
more
sounds like a disaster but as i said i'm
i'm more interested in how the media
plays it like if pr if trump had been
president during all of this would be
with the media be behaving exactly how
it is i just need some more info before
i can
comment more on that uh the covet stuff
sounds a little
bit messy but i didn't quite get enough
info on like
is it really worse like and again why is
no hospital collapsed why did not one of
our lovely homeless centers that we have
here of these you know tents and
buildings these structures that homeless
people build here was there any massive
outbreak in any of those like why did
not one
city somewhere fail mass death like none
of that has happened these are questions
that i think you're allowed to ask i
don't want to get banned from youtube
the day i'm back but these are questions
to ask and then of course the good news
sounds like this larry elder thing could
really be real like how cool would that
be and then i get to call
shapiro and knowles and be like you guys
bailed on cali
but me and lario they're saved like
maybe it could happen so that's where a
lot of my energy is going to be over the
next little bit um
i do want to reiterate
like just like an unbelievable
uh heartfelt and
and authentic
thank you to you guys for allowing me to
do what i did for the last month i am
i'm ready to fight in a way
that is
is stronger and and better
and more prepared than when i left and
that's the purpose of this thing you
know when i this was my fifth august off
the grid and when i did it five years
ago it was a lark it was just like ah
let me just do something interesting and
it's gotten more difficult each year as
my profile is raised and i have more
businesses and more responsibilities and
things like that and that's even just
more reason to do it but i really i was
able over the last month
to just like
get my in order you know i listened
to a lot of jordan peterson interviews
by the way and i
you know i you know we've we've all got
stuff that we're dealing with whether
it's within our families or our own
stuff our own dragon that we have to
face down and i really did a lot of work
on that front and i'm completely and 100
ready to be back in this fight with you
guys i think for me you know the the
challenge over the next couple days
will be how quickly do i get back into
this thing you know it's not creating
videos that's the headache it's not
communicating with my locals community
which is an absolute true joy i mean the
people that really uh fuel this
operation and that i get to really
exchange ideas with them that i respond
to and everything else it's not that it
seems like twitter is the one where most
of the evil exists and i want to really
reevaluate my my behavior with twitter
because that seems to be where the this
endless
hostile thought war is mostly taking
place yeah it takes place in the youtube
comment section and it takes place
on facebook and all the rest of it but
twitter seems to be like a particular
perverse evil but i really am going to
take some of the things that i practiced
over this last month again no phone in
the bedroom
stop watching the news at a certain time
at night um get out there and be
friendly when you're at the the grocery
store or wherever else oh one policy
that david and i did uh institute over
the last couple weeks since we've been
back is when we're when we're walking
clyde i will say hello and smile and say
how you doing to every single neighbor
that is not wearing a mask but i've
decided i'm not saying hello to the mask
people anymore and the reason for that
is what i've realized over the last
couple weeks is that the masked people
are not friendly as a general rule and
of course there's always exceptions to
the rule but the mass people i would say
hi to and they just ignore you they're
actually using it as an excuse to never
be human anymore and what i have found
is the non-masked people tend to be
friendlier and nicer and happier so i
that's what i mean about we're gonna
we're just gonna further split into two
worlds and i and i think that's okay
i think that's okay because the world
that i'm gonna help build and that i'm
going to talk about and that you guys
are going to be part of is going to be a
world that's based on the ideas that
we're always talking about here right
like it's going to be based on the ideas
of individual choice and freedom and
at locals like i'm never going to as
long as i'm part of locals like i'm
never gonna say you have to have a
vaccine to work here it's none of my
business you know what i mean like we're
gonna just build new things and let the
other people
build the things that will be based
on critical race theory let them do
diversity inclusion hirings and all
those things and and i think that's what
will be the split of america and maybe
it feels it feels a little like a civil
war it's not it's not fun to talk about
but at this point this gets me back to
the beginning i just don't see a way
around it but that doesn't mean it has
to be horrible i don't want people
fighting in the streets and and for
those of us that are that are more
freedom focused it's trickier for us
because we can build something good and
they're going gonna still all want a
piece of it right where we don't really
want like they can go build your
institutions build your crappy colleges
and your stupid businesses built on
diversity and build bad products and
have the emmys now and have all of that
stuff i don't want any of that stuff i
don't care about that stuff but they're
going to still want our stuff right
because we're going to build better
products and we're going to build better
businesses so i'm going to really
guys over over the next however long it
is
if there's any way that i can help
anyone that's that's building anything
cool whether it's a business or a
product or a technology like i want to
help promote people i want to hear about
the people that are are fighting for the
right things you know i was in malibu a
couple days ago
and i met this young kid at a store who
said he was a big fan and he found
jordan peterson through me and he said
to me that
that we saved his life
we talked to him for a little bit and
it's like
i'm gonna guess that jordan probably
saved his life more than i did but if if
my job there was only that i introduced
him to jordan peterson this kid had his
life in order he was going to pepperdine
he was he was doing well
and it's like we can build something
better together but we got to do it
together not because we're guilted into
being together
but because we want to save whatever
whatever is left of the good america i
want to fight for for saving it i also
want to just not go crazy in the process
and and i hope that
if if you have been interested in
anything i said here for the last two
hours or just why i took part in this
you know everyone's so amazed that i do
this thing it's like let's rethink our
relationship with this thing before they
just come to get us because it is a
digital war versus the verse us
right now there's a digital world in the
real world i'm sitting in a room wearing
some clothes and this is going out
through those digital pipes and we got
to figure out how to manage what the
future is going to be are we just going
to be people who wear masks and never
live leave our houses and fight with
people online all the time or are we
going to people who dare to get out
there and dare to build new things and
interact with other people and take some
of the lessons that our
parents and grandparents and forefathers
before them learned about about freedom
and the human experience and all that
stuff so i'm feeling great i'm super
psyched about the larry elder part of
this like maybe this thing can happen
maybe this like
wouldn't it be aw
you got a dream right like that's jordan
peterson like you gotta like look at
that star you know and go that's the
thing in the distance so maybe we could
do this and then and then it's like man
if we fixed cali
and shown that show them no enough is
enough
enough is enough
maybe we can fix the rest of this thing
so uh i have a bit of a crazy day today
i haven't even looked at twitter yet
i've started to just check a couple
emails right before some work-related
stuff but i'm going to try to ease back
into everything i will be back normal
time
tomorrow of course at 11 a.m we'll we'll
do a q a just to get i know people are
just going to want to talk mostly about
off the grid stuff so we'll do that
oh and tonight i'm on tucker carlson
tonight i haven't been on in in a while
but i know tucker was interested in the
off-the-grid situation wanted to catch
me up on a couple things uh i don't know
the exact hit time for that but tucker
is on at uh 8 p.m eastern um
and 5 p.m pacific time uh so i hope
you'll tune in and and again guys i just
i really i thank you like
i'm i'm ready to fight with you so you
have afforded me if you watch this and
and especially if you're in the locals
community you've afforded me an
incredible opportunity so that we can do
this thing together and
i thank you i thank you i thank you
and i'll see you tomorrow